sur ce plateau l'un des co auteurs de ce
livre enquête pierre péan
vous dénoncez les investigations à
charge du monde mais votre livre est
calqué sur ce modèle non pour nous c'est
peut-être une instruction à charge
risqueront loaded nous mêmes la face
cachée du monde
bon à longueur d'année monsieur
colombani monsieur plenel parle de la
phase lumineuse nous évidemment on a
essayé de montrer ce que ce que l'on
cache généralement donc et on reprend
effectivement les méthodes habituelles
du journalisme où on ne parle pas des
trains qui arrivent à l'heure mais des
trains qui arrivent en retard et donc et
si on parle beaucoup de haine en fait
c'est un miroir qu'on a qu'on a mis face
à obo pratique du journal le monde et
cette impression puisque ce journal est
à beaucoup de haine il ya dénonce les
gens dénoncent les politiques à la
longueur d'une et bien nous racontons ça
ça donne cette impression mais ce qu'il
était indispensable pour parler
nullement d'aller fouiller dans le passé
du père de jean marie colombani et
d'edwy plenel c'est pas de l'acharnement
non absolument pas d'acharnement nous
n'aurions pas parler des pères si eux
mêmes ne mettait pas au centre de leurs
préoccupations
edwy plenel dans tous ses livres
consacrent au moins un chapitre à son
père est dans le dernier secret de
famille il en parle toujours mille n'en
parle pas dans le quotidien le monde
ça n'a rien à voir avec le journal il
explique les dans l'est dans ces livres
c'est pour expliquer ce qu'ils sont et
quelles sont leurs motivations et pour
le père de colombani dans son dernier
livre les infortunes de la république il
dit même que leur lien entre avec les
liens entre les deux hommes c'est par le
biais des pères donc jamais nous
n'aurions millet père si eux mêmes les
mettais pas sur la place publique alors
affirmé que le coup le monde mattie ses
comptes vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
le représentant de l'association depuis
hier de l'association hubert beuve-méry
qui dit que c'est faux fadoua gillis
quand même toutes vos démonstrations
non pour moi je fais un an il ya un
procès qui va être en cours on va bien
voir ce qui va se passer je tiens mes
tenons l'ailé les comptes de l'intérieur
du monde pour être clair et donc il a
seulement dit que le 13,1 en question il
le savait c'est tout ce qu'il a dit
alors après c'est la présentation nous
nous disons que la présentation à
lecteurs du monde ne pouvait pas se
retrouver dans les comptes qui était qui
sont présentés voilà ce que nous disons
sur les comptes mais nous en disent ont
beaucoup d'autres sur les problèmes de
la diffusion sur les problèmes le nous
racontons comment les secours l'écho en
kiosque la vente du nouveau monde a
diminué par exemple vous dites aussi par
exemple dans votre livre que jean marie
colombani edwy plenel n'aime pas la
france
votre co auteur est souverainiste il a
fait la campagne de jean pierre
chevènement ça vous n'en parlez pas ce
qui apparaît que la console mais c'est
un proche de jean pierre chevènement
c'est si je voulais c'est pas ce qui
apporte c'est l'effet les faits que nous
rapportons tout le reste c'est c'est une
polémique qui est lancée mais je
m'attends à ce qu'on nous réponde sur
sur l'ensemble des faits qui me semble
beaucoup très très important et ce qui a
pas beaucoup de constructions
intellectuelles et pas suffisamment de
preuves et attendait la construction la
coupe quelle construction jeu cancan
quand nous montrons une facture de
lobbying qui montre à l'évidence que le
monde est un pouvoir et qu'ils facturent
son pouvoir
nous amenons toutes les preuves
possibles imaginables pendant dans le
reportage on parlait des journaux
gratuits et bien le groupe
le groupe norvégien a demandé au monde
de l'aider à pénétrer le marché français
et monsieur edwy plenel a envoyé une
facture qu'est ce que c'est du lobbying
et donc ça se sont pas des ehpad
l'idéologie sérieux ça n'a rien à voir
ce sont des faits que nous démontrons et
nous entendons bien nous placer sous
l'angle des faits et non sous l'angle de
la polémique
alors justement vous reprochez au monde
avancer la campagne d'edouard balladur
or il n'a pas été élu est-ce que vous
leur attribuez pas un pouvoir qu'ils
n'ont pas finalement dans m'attendais au
début ils se trouvent
au début ils ont même annoncé en une que
l'élection n'avait plus besoin d'être
d'avoir lieu puisque les sondages
montraient donc
nous montrons qu'ils ont ils se sont
engagés leur présidente conseil de
surveillance était un conseiller très
proche de balladur et c'est tout après
qu' il ya eu d'autres événements dans le
déroulement de la campagne qui font que
monsieur balladur n'a pas été élu merci
pierre péan est revenu sur ce plateau